individuation and non-duality
in order to be accurate on
this subject
because it's so dearly
the essence of the nature of reality
we have to be very precise
with what we say
and in order to understand
the essence of this subject
one has to have
turned inward for quite
a while quite intensively
in order to get it
and so because of that we're gonna start
at a pretty
advanced stage of understanding this
so one of the
most fundamental
ways to begin the exploration of the
subject
is to take it from the essence
of infinity
so when you have
a boundless
infinitude of all possibilities that are
being
explored what you get is you get a
manifestation
as a universe that has
all of these earth's orbiting stars
with different vehicles of sentience
that then undergo a process of
exploration or play
and so now you're starting to get a
little bit of the idea
of that individuation within
the non-duality
there's all of these vehicles of
sentience
within this cosmic storm
this processing system called life
so the way
that infinity expresses itself
can be thought of as individuation
in non-duality
infinity has to use the process
of individuation in non-duality
in order for it to create a mechanism
of exploration a mechanism of play
so bathe in this understanding more and
more
sort of relax yourself into this
understanding
okay my nature
is an absolute infinity
that is completely boundless with no
limits
that is eternally exploring all
possibility
and the mechanism the physics
that me as absolute infinity
uses to explore eternally this
infinite possibility space is
universes is individuation
within those universes that then
plays with itself when these two
individuals come and talk to
each other it is that one infinite
intelligence
that is exploring with itself through
these individuations
the more that the individuation
decentralizes itself
into the cosmic storm the more it
understands the essence of non-duality
the more that it understands
the very centerless nature that is the
cosmic storm
so the more that the individuation
decentralizes itself
and typically that comes from the
release
of all of the subconscious conditioning
that is built up in the individual
over the span of decades
when the individual turns inward and
begins shining the light of awareness on
all of those little subconscious packets
of conditioning in its neural
architecture
and it begins dissolving and liberating
itself from needing to be
seen and needing to be validated and
needing to be worthy
from the need to pursue all of these
external worldly pleasures incessantly
just to figure out the very emptiness of
them
that creates a decentralization of the
individuation to the point where it
begins identifying itself
as infinity as life itself
as the cosmic storm so then when it
speaks to another individual it is no
longer speaking to a separate entity but
it is speaking
to infinity itself it's speaking to
itself it's non-duality
speaking to itself via two individuals
you need the 8 billion individuals
on this planet in order for
that very non-dual cosmic storm to be
able to take on
all of these different perspectives and
all of these different experiences in
order
for it to play with itself
so decentralize the [ __ ] out of the
individual
until the point where it begins
identifying itself
as life itself as the cosmos itself
which takes on this very centerless
non-dual nature
but then at the same time it is able
to also have the beauty of the
individuated perspective
simultaneously
so you go inward all the way to empty
yourself of
all of these conditioned layers of
identity merge
with the non-dual nature at the core of
our essence
and then you're able to include the
individuation
your unique costume your unique
performance on the eternal stage that is
infinity
that's the trick
and this has been taught by nisargadza
the maharaja and many of the other
incredible mystics that you have to go
through a process of nettie neddy which
is not this not that you have to
create this negation first you have to
negate
all of the subconscious programming and
conditioning
and negate your identity as even a body
itself
for you to be able to recognize the
saliency or the poignancy or how
paramount it is
for you to be the nature of infinite
possibility
itself it's so formless and
indescribable
for you to identify yourself as infinity
itself
and then only then
can you properly include as the second
step
so you negate first to go all the way
inward and then you
include in the second step all of the
beauty
of your costume all of the beauty of
what you're wearing
in the performance on the eternal stage
and that's how you get this
individuation and non-duality
it has to be done this way it's a
physics
it's a mechanism of infinity it has to
be done this way
when you tap into the very fractal-like
nature of the diamond that we
are you see that the universe when
viewed as a
fractal diamond it has all of
these unique individuations that are not
separate from each other
so you view it more and more as all of
these unique individuals across the
entire universe across
all of the planets and all of the star
systems
all of them are diamond in nature
all of them are as it is absolute
perfection
and yet at the same time
all of those unique individuals are
undergoing a process of perfecting
because 10 years ago where this
individuation was
was a much more egoic separate
contracted
identity and today it is way
more liberated way more in tune
with its true nature and so there has
been some sort of an evolutionary
process there has been some sort of a
perfecting process
at the same time that it has been
absolute perfection the entire time
and that is true simultaneity
can you simultaneously be
the absolute non-dual
cosmic storm that is centerless
completely decentralized from your
individual identity and yet
simultaneously
when somebody asks you hey atlas
you know where were you born can you
still be able to
retrieve from your memory banks of this
experience in this specific
creation where you were born yes
of course you can and that's the nature
of being able to retrieve some sort of
information
about your unique expression as an
individual
but the game is to not become attached
to those networks of memory to all of
that conditioning
to all of what's buried in the
subconscious but to liberate yourself
from it to dissolve it to the degree of
which
you're so unbelievably free
you've turned all the way inward until
you've merged with this non-dual nature
and then you've included all of the
unique aspects to your individuation
that you can access as you need but
you're not a slave
to it
again it's a fundamental
physics a mechanism of our
true infinitude of that non-dual nature
as one infinite creator one infinite
intelligence endlessly
exploring all possibility to use
individuation it has to use
individuation
it has to you have to understand that it
has to use individuation
there's no other way you have to fractal
yourself
out self similarly as all of these
unique
costumes in order for you to play with
yourself
in order to play with yourself you have
to
fractal yourself as all of these
self-similar
costumes that are then talking and
playing
with itself as a decentralized cosmic
storm that is centerless
in non-dual nature
so that's the true simultaneity you know
you are in essence infinite possibility
your truest essence is pure potentiality
infinite possibility which then
is manifested as these beautiful
explorative universes that use the
mechanism of individuation
in order to play with itself
for that one intelligence to play with
itself
through the fractal self-similar
individuations
so when these individuals decentralize
their identity
to such a degree that they merge with
that non-duality
it then enables them to more
harmonically
more perfectedly include
their costume their unique firework
from a place of no lack from a place of
pure
love from a place of pure coherence from
a place of pure clarity
from a place of pure service pure
shepherding the rest of the creation to
awaken
that's the game this is the game that we
play
this is how to view individuation and
non-duality
this is how to view a very high level
metaphysical concept
that is typically completely
unable to be explored because there's
not
enough of an understanding that is
polymathic
that has drawn upon enough fields to be
able to merge
the simultaneity of the non-dual nature
with the individuated nature you have to
recognize that those
two are ultimately one which is what is
meant by not
to you have to use
individuation as a physics as a
mechanism
in order to actually explore infinite
possibility
ultimately there is one and it uses
individuation as a self-similar
mechanism
to explore to play with itself and this
is beautiful when you
truly have this anchored in your essence
when you have this anchored in your
heart
you know how to both respect the [ __ ]
out of the decentralized cosmic
storm centerless at play with itself
and yet also realize the beauty
of all of the unique individuals the
unique
costumes that are being explored
all those unique fireworks
that are all discussing and
at play with themselves trying to figure
out
who are we truly what are we doing here
how to maximize our potential
and that's how the mechanism works
that's how the physics works
absolute infinity undergoes a process of
wanting to explore a possibility
manifest the universe it then immerses
itself
in the process of fractaling out
as these self-similar individuals in
order to
undergo a process of exploring a
sleeping followed by
awakening to its true
nature repeatedly as different universes
using different designs using different
costumes using different vehicles
and it'll never come to the end of its
infinite exploration
it'll never come to the end it's
absolutely boundless there are no limits
and this is but a manifestation of that
infinite potential
boom
cool i hope this was valuable
and resonant
and i would love to hear where you're at
with understanding this in the comments
below
and if the video brought you value give
it a like subscribe to the channel if
you haven't yet share the video with
other people that you feel like this
would be resonant
for and that's all
infinite love thank you